Speaker 1: I want to talk to you today about
Republican hypocrisy, which has reached heretofore
unseen levels.
But this isn't about one thing like, OK, you
know, we've talked about vaccines and hypocrisy
before.
We had a decade where we talked about gay
marriage and hypocrisy from the right.
This is a big picture issue that if we can't
pierce in some way, we may never make progress
on some really important issues that affect
the United States in the world.
This story was actually inspired by a sub
Reddit user who goes by the name department
chair who posted about this a few days ago
on the sub Reddit.
Really good post.
And I realized this is something we should
be talking about right now and really exposing
the feckless nature of what is supposedly
the right wing philosophy at this point in
time, because Republicans claim to have at
the center of their political philosophy the
principles of nonintervention by government
into people's lives and less completely necessary
of not regulating business unless completely
necessary, of a smaller government that does
fewer things, being a better government, all
else being equal.
This has been floating around in Republican
circles, at least I mean, but popularized
during the Reagan era, although you could
probably find examples of it before then as
well.
Now, you and I, we've seen this be utter garbage
at the micro level.
They say small government, but they want the
government to ban gay marriage.
Wait, hold on.
But that doesn't make sense.
They say small government, but they want the
government policing cannabis at the state
and federal level.
And that doesn't make sense.
But the reality is that Republican policy
on endless issues is incredibly interventionist,
anti libertarian collectivist, which they
claim to be against and in some cases is even
oppressive to the degree that they want to
put policy in place.
And as our Reddit user department chair points
out, often, this is the case with victimless
crimes, flag burning as an example.
Same sex marriage, the Pledge of Allegiance
in school.
So just step back for a second and think about
all of the areas where Republicans self professed
so.
Called small government conservatives have
demanded that government take action over
the last many decades.
I mean, OK, abortion decisions that should
be made between a patient and a doctor for
50 years now ban it federally.
They say ban it at the state level.
They say regulate how many what procedures
do you have to have before and have an abortion,
transvaginal ultrasound and on and on and
on regulate family planning.
And they claim to be small government conservatives.
That's been going on for 50 years, for more
than a decade.
It was the government should ban same sex
marriage.
That was a huge political issue.
For more than a decade, the battle lines on
gay rights have shifted since the 2005 Supreme
Court decision, but that was it for a decade.
Ban everything, get the government involved,
prevent teachers from deciding what to teach,
banned the teaching of critical race theory.
Control what teachers teach as if you know
more than they know.
The war on drugs, the war on drugs, policing
of drugs, prosecution, incarceration, using
it to justify surveillance.
War on drugs alone is like ten items that
that sort of follow from that burning flags,
something the Supreme Court has decided is
constitutionally protected speech.
These Republicans, they want to ban it.
They want to punish people.
A couple of months ago, we did a segment where
I think it was at a Trump rally.
An interviewer was asking people what should
happen if somebody burns a flag.
Some Republicans called for the death penalty
for burning a flag, OK, surveillance, an entire
area in and of itself.
Now, I will say there are some libertarians,
actual libertarians, not just like reactionary
right wingers who hide under the name libertarian.
There are some actual libertarians who are
against much of the the surveillance activity
that has been put in place by Patriot Act,
NSA, etc. over the last decade, more.
But a lot of these right wingers say, no,
no, no, we need that.
We need that in order to find antifa.
We need that in order to monitor Muslims or
whatever the case may be.
OK, mandating the Pledge of Allegiance in
schools, I mean, you've got to be kidding,
right?
No, no.
Many concerts, small government government
involved only when absolutely necessary, requiring
wanting to require the Pledge of Allegiance
be recited in school.
And yet they have the audacity to mention
government intrusion and small government
and freedom and liberty when they come out
against vaccination requirements, even by
private businesses, when they come out against
mask mandates by municipalities or businesses.
And they are even against private businesses
simply saying, if you want to work here, you
need a vaccine or if you want to shop here,
you need a vaccine.
Think of that.
They claim to want businesses to do to be
able to do whatever the hell they want.
They say don't regulate business.
Business will decide what's best and the market
will punish them if they do the wrong thing.
But they say owner no, make it illegal for
a business to require a business to require
an employee be vaccinated, make it illegal
for a business to require masks, make it illegal
for a business to require customers to show
proof of vaccination.
And why is it.
It's also simple, guys.
It's because their principles are B.S.
They don't really have principles, at least
not anymore.
They are about whatever talking point sounds
good right now.
And it gets us what we want right now, that's
what we believe in, that's what we stand for
until it's no longer convenient, and then
they're against that very thing.
Their one principle is somehow figure out
a way to own the libs.
It's truly one of the most bad faith political
movements I can think of.
And, you know, you go back and you look at
the racist origins of the war on drugs in
reaction to the civil rights movement of the
late 50s, early 60s.
You look at the anti welfare movement of the
Reagan era and how racially tinged that was
and all these different there was a lot of
bad faith going on, but at this point, they're
barely even pretending to have principles,
even their principles, like you hear them.
And it's like, come on, dude, that's B.S.
You know, you don't even believe that because
look at example.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, where
you abandon those principles because the outcome
of applying that principle would no longer
be the one you want.
So why do we care about this?
We care about it because since it has become
the orthodoxy of the Republican Party, I mean,
you want to see hypocrisy.
Mitch McConnell on Supreme Court picks.
Right?
Just just look, it's the perfect example of
how this unbridled and unpunished hypocrisy
gets them political winds.
And so if we don't find a way to pierce this,
I worry seriously that the left will struggle
to really make progress on some major important
issues.
Let me know what you think.
You can find me and follow me on Twitter at
David Pakman.
It's great to be back.
We have a really big show for you today.
I'll talk about my vacation on the bonus show.
Let me just preview one aspect of the bonus
show today.
Positive.
Covid.
Test.
That's all I'm going to say on today's bonus
show.
All right, let's get back into it, it's great
to be back in the studio today.
I do want to remind you, not only is this
program mostly funded by membership's who
sign up at Join Pakman Dotcom members who
get memberships at Join Pakman Dotcom.
We did do our 16th anniversary special on
Monday.
If you missed it and you want the discount
code, just email info at David Pakman.
Dotcom, today is a great day to sign up.
Why?
I have a story from my vacation, which I will
tell on today's bonus show, which I will summarize
only as positive covid test.
This is an incredible story.
OK, on today's bonus show, sign up at Join
Pakman Dotcom.